hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure mal
Wanne und ich bin ganz aufgeregt denn es
gibt heute eine neue Folge Wanne will
wissen heute geht es um
Sushi sui und was wäre ich denn ohne
meine reizende Assistentin
[Applaus]
andre
hi okay und jetzt machen wir Sushi oder
wie ja aber
andre ja Vanessa wir sehen ja noch gar
nicht richtig japanisch aus oh das ist
aber eigentlich ganz okay okay dann lass
uns das
Ändern jetzt kann es losgehen das ist
einfach nur
rassistisch heute dreht es sich um das
Japan Sushi Sting Kit andre möchtest du
das zusammen mit mir Auspacken oh
ja oh was fallen da für tolle Sachen
raus hier haben wir erstmal Kubota Sushi
Reis nein busenreis der sushiis Check
die Sushi Algen Check ja ich habe den
Bambus geöffnet ja dann zeig uns doch
mal was da drin ich den dam rollen wir
das ganze
Teil
gut so und jetzt haben wir hier eine
Tüte
mit ganz vielen kleinen Dingen sieht aus
wie
ketchuptüten ne irgendwas das ist das
ist wir sollten mal die Packung holen
und les
was R nach Plastik daseren wir jetzt
alles wunderschön auf den Teller richten
das super an und das zeige ich dann
einfach mal so in die Kamera sehr gut so
hab jetzt bisschen Sushi Packung ups das
tut mir leid ich muss mir eine neue
Packung
kaufen okay ich kauf dir eine neue
Packung wollen wir einfach mal die Steps
ja ach so womit wir unser Sushi befüllen
wir haben die Arme Studentenversion
gewählt einmal eine Gurke das ist eine
ein Gemüse ja das ist grün farblich
gesehen sehr wasserreich
wunderschön und einmal typisch japanisch
kitcat
aber das dicke das dicke kitat damit
damit es schön reinpasstck
K ke hier oder reisbälchen sushirchen
hast du noch mal Glück gehabt Sushi Star
K ja dann machen wir jetzt erstm den
Sushi
Reis yay Sushi waschen erst Sushi
waschen dann Uschi waschen lass uns
Sushi
machen
Rassismus so Andrej könntest du jetzt
bitte für uns den Reis waschen aber
gerne doch zuerst öffne ich diese Tüte
hier einfach bisschen ohne dass was
daneben geht tut gucken wir uns mal die
schöne Bank an ja so sieht die ich
einfach wie ich das gerade mache so ja
bisschen Professionalität ja ja auch
wenn KF gerade da ist aber er kann uns
auch
ich liebe dich KF okay los geht's oh
ja das wird gut das ist ein schönes
Gefühl deine he gewaschen ja gerade eben
in diesem Moment was
du musst deine Hand davorhten wie meine
Hand
[Musik]
davorhten wieso machst du das eigentlich
nicht ja so viel besser kan
besser bin ich der mus die Hand voll
clever also auf der Anleitung steht dass
man sie benutzen soll also ich glaube
das auch die bessere
Variante ja aber weil hier alle Siebe
quasi gerade in Benutzung sind und wir
einfach zu faul sind Andre ich habe dir
gleich gesagt mit einem Sieg geht besser
das ist alles die Schuld des Internets
wir haben jetzt super sauberen Reis und
müssen
375 ml
wasserzufügen und das geben wir jetzt zu
dem Reis dazu und sollen das so
einwirken lassen eine ganze fucking
halbe Stunde lang das ist ja grauenvoll
was machen wir währenddessen mit einem
jumpcard
andre vielleicht möchtest du die Gurke
schneiden vielleicht möchte ich auch was
anderes
schneiden z.B Menschen aber die Gurke
tut's erstmal für den Moment oder gut
dass ich sie gerade auseinander gestückt
habe ja das war super
intelligent so dann ist doch mal
Streifen und jetzt vielleicht noch mal
in der Mitte oder so ist das ein guter
Streifen für
ein denk dran
ich B aber
schneller GL ichum Fix wird uns
umbringen wenn er sieht wie wir mit den
Messern hier umgehen diese Scheiben sind
perfekt und
die diese hier nicht nee die hast auch
du gemacht die habe ich
gemachtin
okay nein deine Finger deine
Finger okay während wir hier so
schreiben könntest du ja mal verraten
wie dein Kanal heißt
hallo mein Kanal heißt andre mogimi
einfach andre und dann Martha Otto
Gustav Heinrich Matha ID und das ist
dann alles da abgebissen ja aber das ist
immer noch gut nein das ist nicht gut
abgebissen du brauchst die Gurke nicht
dekorativ auf Nein
andre andre das ist nicht dekorativ
andre ist einfach nur Mindestmaß
anästhetik
andre so wir haben die Gurken jetzt
schön auf ein Felle angerichtet solange
wir warten jetzt gibt es noch ein kitcut
zum Nachtisch den schneiden wir jetzt
auch schöne in schöne Scheiben die
Vorstellung ist ja irgendwie ekelhaft
aber okay wir kriegen das
oh
oh ja oh nee nee nee nee also also ich
freue mich auf das kitcat Sushi also das
wird super präsentiert von Nestle das
sind die besten Menschen kauft alle
Produkte von Nestle vor allem das Wasser
das hat's mir angetan so was machen wir
jetzt jetzt müssen wir warten bis der
Reis fertig ist oder ja vielleicht
sollten wir auch dann ein brampgart
machen oder so ein neuer jumpcut zilich
Scheiße der
jumpcut
hey so jetzt hat der Reis schön
eingewirkt ich zeig ihn noch mal kurz ja
so perfekt und jetzt müssen wir jetzt
wird's kompliziert wir müssen das Wasser
zum Kochen bringen okay dann müssen wir
die hipze reduzieren in garen lassen 5
bis 10 Minuten und dann müssen wir
Köchel lassen auf niedrig hze noch mal
15 Minuten und dann muss 10
minutenen reiskochen ist eine Kunst das
ist eine den Kunst und jeder der sie
nicht schätzt wie z.B diese Gesellen
hier der ist raus so dann guck wir mal
wie funktioniert denn dieser Herd
eigentlich können wir noch einmal
erwähnen wie lustig er ins gebüch fällt
er ist so lustig er fällt ins gebüch und
lacht ganz Recht sieht mich an ich falle
ins gebüch und keiner von den beiden
hilft ihn was sag natürlich nicht
natürlich nicht okay dann lassen wir den
Reich jetzt mal kochen Köchen und und
dann sehen wir uns wieder wenn der Reis
fertig gchelt dann machen wir ein
kleinen jumpcut jetzt wieder oder okay
ich renne dich hinein okay B du bereit
alles
klar
R
Reis Reis
re ist zu Sushi Reis muss man hier ist
noch mal der Reis super geworden super
super Reis super Reis super super Reis
super Suppe andre was hatten nicht
gesprochen dass du jetzt ein bisschen
asiatischer sprichst
okay super Reis
ne super le also andre was haben wir
hier
le genau er sagt ständig Reis oder das
Japaner überhaupt
das drauf nicht na ja aber riecht ein
bisschen
[Musik]
streng
Armen kannst du den
ganzen
leer
V
so man muss die Matte in frisch Folie
packen so ich mache einfach mal während
du das machst die eigen auf das übrigens
nor eigen das sagt mir überhaupt nichts
aber das wird schon irgendwas sein
vielleicht haben wir Sushi Experten
unter den Zuschauern jetzt sagen Alter
yakinuri ist das beste
wow das FT sich nicht wie Sushi
an wie an
also wir halbieren jetzt einmal die
Scheiße gibt einfach das Video einen
Daumen nach oben wen ich findet dass
Andre aussieht wie ein
Asiate lustig dass du sagst denn ich bin
Asiat du bist Iraner das ist in Asien
nicht hier irgend hinlegen damit man das
schön Rollen kann ja das nice für unser
normales Sushi brauchen wir auch eine
Dingens of water because
der Reis wie man sieht ist sehr klebrig
deshalb macht man immer mal wieder so
den hier boah die e Stint voll
krass oder RST du die ich rie
nichts ich habe meinen Geruchsinn in
Vietnam
verloren du bist
doof wer kommt denn da oh ich habe euch
was zu essen gebracht aber wir kochen
doch gerade Sushi warum h
bravoer das
ist also das kann ich erklären das kann
ich echt
erklären aber ich tu es nicht ach süß
ihr macht z Schokolade
ja kitat Sushi hier für den Fall D es
nichtd geil von einer nicht näher
geschriebenen amerikanischen
Burgerkette du meinst Burger King m
King in die MTE kommt ein bisschen
Frischkäse für den für den richtigen
Taste mit dem Frischkäse auf dem Sushi
ten wir jetzt ein bisschen
grine oh oh jetzt kommt zum Rollen
rüber das ist schon ziemlich
professionell
hier ist es ein bisschen
lern mal so ein
bisschen es fällt leider auseinander wir
versuchen noch mal die zweite Variante
jetzt gibt es ein
Sushi mit Schokolade weil der andre sich
das so gern gewünscht hat ja das habe
ich so für unser schokoladenshi Tun
wir Schokolade in der
Sushi
es ist einfach kitcut Sushi oh Gott es
sieht so schön aus und jetzt geht's ans
testen
testen testen testen du musst aber
vorher alles auf so einem schönen Teller
bisschen anrichten
oder
ja
oh das ist aber
ein großes Sushi jetzt geht's an Sushi
essen okay
Frost und ohne Gurke mus ich
nachholen jetzt kommen wir zum Kid Sushi
das
Sojasoße
ich na gut re
Prost also B auf den
Eigengeschmack ist ist echt ganz gut ich
glaub wir sind auf was gestoßen oder was
mein
du no mehr nein das tut dir im Mund weh
das tut nicht im Mund weh das ist gut
jetzt musst du so dramatische kannz
zimmermusik
[Musik]
reinmachen das ist
geil das ist Sushi Sushi
mitabi so was ist denn dein Fazit zu dem
Sushi
Starter stusi stusi schwarter Kit ich
find das Japan Sushi Starter Kit super
und du andre ich finde es auch ganz gut
ich habe keine Ahnung von Sushi ich habe
keine Ahnung vom Reis kochen
aber was ich sagen kann ist dass das
ganz
gutes das ist doch die
Hauptsache ich meine wenn man das mit so
Lieferservice zugeschickt kriegen würde
würde man sagen I was ist das was ist
das für eine scheiße was ist das für
eine schlechte Kacke die lass ich
zurückgehen da gehe ich doch lieber zum
BurgerKing ja das war's mit Wanne will
wissen oder das war mit W will wissen
wen ihr lust auf noch mehr Videos hab
die findet ihr links und rechts aber ich
muss sagen ich fin das Sushi fast noch
besser ja zumind das mit kickat
und wir sehen uns das nächste Mal
vergiss nicht auf and Kanal zu gehen
genauti und andre sind zwei Kanäle wer
wer hinkriegen meine ich verlink ich
verlink beides dann dementsprechend an
den Orten die
gehört das war's tschüss auf Wiedersehen
noch ein letzter jumpc okay
jumpcut